what up space fam golsan here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story and
i just gotta say right now this was a
bombshell of a chapter with so many
crazy things happening including the
return of blackbeard his shocking new
bounty and power the fate of boa and
kobe is revealed we see more of shanks
and marco and find out whether or not
marco finally joins the red hair pirates
and even the dark king rayleigh makes an
appearance and says some truly shocking
things so make sure to stay tuned for
this crazy chapter also because so many
things happened i forgot to mention this
but also we find out why exactly yamato
is not joined the crew we get the
reasoning so we have that to look
forward to as well chin a little
pirating within and smash that like
button if you enjoyed these one-piece
reviews and want to keep them coming be
a smashing power king rather than
passing lorochi and watch your screen
deservedly light up with fireworks make
this the video you subscribe if you
haven't already and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece reviews and updates and now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all so this chapter is
called the captain kobe incident which
is intriguing in and of itself i love
how well this chapter fleshed out what
other characters were doing while the
wano arc was taking place and if you
have no idea what's gonna happen don't
worry we'll get into it soon the cover
of story shows katakuri and oven
fighting amongst themselves because of
the effects of caesar's hallucinogenic
gas another hint to what's happening in
the outside world and once again i gotta
say this was an exciting match up for a
cover story series germa versus big mom
pirates so props to oda for that so we
jump to near sphinx aka whitebeard's
homeland we see a lone ship it turns out
to be the red hair pirates ship and they
were giving marco a lift if you'll
remember shanks asked marco to join his
crew before when he visited whitebeard's
ship to talk about blackbeard so here
the idea is raised again whitebeard is
gone and so marco is asked you're really
not going to join the crew marco and
then marco responds by laughing and
saying quit dreaming he says he's way
too old and worn out to keep playing
babysitter for you great pirates so i
guess that was a sort of backhanded
insult since he finished off in a
positive way by saying they are great
pirates still though marco is 45 years
old and ben beckman is 50 years old so
he's definitely not too old to be a
pirate but i get it if he feels worn out
after everything still he's a phoenix
and will rise again it's just a matter
of how long it takes either way it's
good to see marco and the red-haired
pirates so friendly and on such good
terms shanks tries one last time saying
it's not like he's a handful or anything
and asks beckman to back him up and
beckman is like afraid i can't and
considering his change in hair color
from black when we first saw him to all
gray or even all white at this point you
can see that it definitely hasn't been
carefree living for him i mentioned that
he looked worn out last time we saw him
so marco probably made the right choice
although other carefree characters like
lucky roo seem to laugh everything off
and don't really appear to age that much
marco though is definitely more similar
to beckman in personality marco leaves
saying see you around with a smile on
his face but it's good to know if things
go down he may well show up to help the
red hair pirates and or the straw hats
then we get the yamato not joining the
crew explanation and it's exactly
another point i brought up before yamato
has decided not to join and when asked
to become a pirate yamato replies you
probably already know this but the
forest guy which by the way i love the
fact that he's just referred to as the
forest guy was only driven off thanks to
whoever caused that immense burst of
haki i really like the fact that
shanks's hockey was addressed here and
not just left unspoken and ignored
yamato brings up what i've been saying a
lot which is that kaido being gone
created a power vacuum and momo and the
red scabbers just aren't enough to keep
intruders from coming especially when
you consider pluton is there because of
that yamato can't just abandon everybody
now and that's again a perfect thing to
say for the guardian deity of llano
fruit user and luffy eventually gets
convinced when it's pointed out that
neither of them would enjoy their
adventures if they were always worried
about wano luffy says that yamato is
right that would be a huge load off his
mind so he leaves momo and the others to
yamato now even this may not be enough
to deter people from coming to wano but
the fact that yamato was able to hold
off kaido for a while and the fact that
wado's not under luffy's protection
makes me more okay with them leaving
wano and expecting things to be okay now
in theory yamato could help hold back a
strong opponent and give luffy and his
crew more time to respond to the threat
if possible either way i think yamato
staying makes a lot of sense as you know
if you've listened to our latest one
piece podcast episode link in the
description and i really don't have a
problem with it even if having a
mythical wolf god fruit on the crew
would be very cool and yes there was a
pun there i love how zoro adds here that
yamato should be careful since momo has
a lot of pride zoro says not to wound it
it's a small moment but one of many that
show how close zorro and momo got in a
swordmaster and student sense we saw a
similar moment recently when momo rushed
into a room excited asking zorro to
teach him something new only to be
devastated when he found out that they
had already left during this flashback
we also see marco saying there is a ship
nearby that will give him a lift so
he'll head off this of course is the red
haired ship luffy finally thanks marco
for saving him during the marine forward
arc which is a nice moment and i'm glad
we got that and it's made even nicer
when marco comments that he's sure ace
would be proud to see how far luffy has
come you gotta love luffy's big bright
grin here marco says to them that the
times belong to you youngsters stay
strong in a sense yeah but in another
sense marco needs to stop acting like
he's 70 years old when the dude is just
5 years older than blackbeard a major
player of the new era but hey i respect
his right to an early retirement if he
wants it now things really pick up from
here we get to amazon lilly it's pointed
out that it's the first time in history
men have invaded like this and that the
town is in bad shape as long as beau is
here the navy won't stop coming so a
situation similar to mihawks and so it
would have been cool to see her join
cross guild too however she goes down a
different road for now she thinks that
since it's come to this it would be
better to go and marry luffy which is
hilarious since as pointed out she
always thinks that it has nothing to do
with this current situation we then get
a flashback to a few weeks prior we see
the marines attacking and another big
development is revealed namely that new
pacifistas the seraphims are being
deployed on the front lines they're
experimenting with them and are
recording what happens this pacifista
takes the form of a little girl and so
it's hard for anyone to fight her just
as all this is going on they see a
pirate ship incoming and it's blackbeard
my favorite villain so i'm hyped at this
point it's even proclaimed that an
emperor's crew is here and they feel
blackbeard seaquake he explains that he
came for the pirate empress and that he
won't let a power like hers fall into
the navy's clutches blackbeard is not
trying to marry her or anything from the
looks of it he just wants her power when
devin points out how boa has a gorgeous
face and that her head would make a
wonderful trophy blackbeard responds she
can do whatever as long as they take her
powers vasco then suggests they could
have even more fun with her if they took
her alive so whoever gets their way here
it's definitely bad news for both it's
funny how the marines are waiting to see
if they can engage blackbeard while
blackbeard just says he's not here for
them fleas and deals with them with one
wave of his guragura nomi hand then we
even see kobe join the battle which is
adding to the hypeness of this flashback
he says he's not surprised by
blackbeard's appearance since he knew
other pirates would want a piece of the
former warlords kobe says they are not
looking for a fight if boa surrenders
herself he promises they'll leave
immediately it's probably not such a bad
offer if you think about what blackbeard
would do to her nevertheless is
pointless boa says she'll never submit
to another's captivity which must be
that conker's hockey personality coming
through it looks like bo is preparing to
use her powers when blackbeard's cruise
starts being taken down by a new
pacifista they say nothing faces the
thing and blackbeard is shocked to see
the white hair brown skin and black
wings it's clear that the marines use
lunarian godly genes to help make these
pacifistas all the more powerful he's
shocked that what looks like a kid took
them all down but then we see the
pacifista split a giant mountain like
it's nothing with a slash it's
reminiscent of when mihawk cut the giant
iceberg at this point blackbeard
realizes it's a pacifista he blocks an
attack with his armament haki but it's
clear that these pacifistas are a threat
and he even says this is huge obviously
the pacifist that doesn't take down
blackbeard he uses black hole to deal
with the situation then we jump to boa
who has started using her powers to turn
many a marine into stone including
helmepo and vice admiral yamakaji the
pacifist of there is causing kobe to
worry as he says for it to stop smashing
the people who've been turned to stone
and that that's an order bola does
succeed in turning devin and vasco into
stone but blackbeard does get his hand
on her which nullifies her powers we get
a crazy panel blackbeard is holding boa
by the neck as kobe stares helplessly at
the situation the bounties of these two
are revealed and they are both
impressive boa's new bounty is
1.659 billion while blackbeard's new
bounty is
3.996 billion practically the same as
shanks says only a bit lower i said that
i expected blackbeard's bounty would
have grown too along with luffy's and in
this flashback it clearly already had
this makes more sense since blackbeard
is obviously the big antagonist luffy
has to overcome and so he needs to have
a bigger bounty to make it feel like
luffy is still the underdog and to keep
things interesting blackbeard says he's
had his eye on boa for quite a while she
says it's her beauty which makes the
power formidable and that if he kills
her all his friends will remain statues
the inheritor of her power won't be able
to release them now that is a big
bargaining chip to be sure and this
whole battle has shown how invaluable
boa can be to any crew what i'd love to
see is boa being the final member of the
straw hats although sanji probably
wouldn't like moving down to fifth place
in terms of the bounty ranking but
forget taking down one yaku commander as
blackbeard said most of his crew has
been petrified and he even praises her
saying you sure got us good even kobe
says he knew beau is far trickier than
anyone expected as we zoom out i love
how we see an image of luffy's bounty
picture in front of the palace it's
amazing but the situation is still dire
blackbeard says i quote seems like we're
at a bit of an impasse doesn't it hero
referring to kobe he continues you did
me a favor at rocky port that made it
possible for me to oust ochoku and
become the boss of pirate island and if
you're wondering ochoku was also a
member of the infamous rox pirates and
it makes sense that blackbeard will
eventually overcome him as someone who
seems to be the new generation's roxdy
zebic he asks kobe if he unhands boa
does he think she'll play nice and turn
everyone back to normal kobe just says
it would be a headache if she didn't
restore the marines boas says she'll do
it if the two get off the island it's
quite an interesting situation a sort of
mexican standoff if you like westerns
blackbeard doesn't buy it though feeling
like if he did let her go he and kobe
would just be turned to stone it's
interesting how he's talking here like
him and kobe are on the same side
against boa as if he cares whether or
not kobe gets turned to stone but i
guess he does kind of care as we'll
learn in a bit blackbeard says he
honestly doesn't think any man could
resist bola's charms blackbeard says
it's a real head scratcher but he
guesses he has to kill her kobe is
begging him to wait and not throw away
all those lives but strategically
blackbeard's decision makes sense yet he
could lose crew members but he'll
continue to live and in this case like
in chess the king is the most important
however if he lets her go in the naive
hope that she might return his crew it
could easily mean the end of his life
he'd be powerless and his fate would be
entirely in her hands but just then
rayleigh shows up to blackbeard's shock
and really to everyone's shock he
apologizes to boa for his lateness and
everyone is just odd by his greatness i
told you how insane is this chapter oda
really delivered here i love how he
refers to yonko blackbeard 2 he just
says whitebeard's old apprentice huh i
know it's immature to admit this he says
but i really don't like you i love the
fact that he just calls him whitebeard's
old apprentice like he's a kid at a
grown-up table the pirate king's right
hand man showing up also freaks out kobe
as well his eyes pop out as if luffy was
using his toon powers on him
interestingly enough the dark king
decides to enforce a compromise where
the people turn to stone are released
and he will ensure that this
de-escalates without issue we later find
out why he may have been so kind to
blackbeard here he adds then the
invaders will leave the island and he
won't allow any funny business we jump
back to present day former empress of
amazon lily shukuyaku is here and yes
it's revealed that she is the ex-captain
of the cuja pirates rayleigh is thanked
for saving the day and this is big what
he says right now he says to be frank we
got lucky circumstances allowed me to
resolve things with my reputation i've
gotten old i'm pretty certain i wouldn't
win a head-on fight against blackbeard
these days now yes rayleigh is not in
his prime but it's still huge praise for
blackbeard and chances are he let
blackbeard have his crew back because if
he didn't he knew blackbeard would be
more likely to fight and then raylee
would probably lose if you ever needed a
sign that we are in the new era it's
when the dark king says blackbeard would
beat him compared to how blackbeard
handled whitebeard pre-timeskip needing
his crew to help him with an old injured
and sick whitebeard this is huge news
coming from another old era legend it's
clear that like luffy blackbeard got a
lot stronger during the time skip the
pacifists are then brought up and it's
noted that they had no scratches on them
after everything that happened and that
one of them looked like boa when she was
a kid so not only is the lunarian stuff
being used they're also using boa's
beauty to their advantage and like i
mentioned there was one that launched an
attack reminiscent to mihawks slash so
it seems like they're using old warlord
powers and putting them into these
pacifistas but i never really get that
excited about pacifistas because i feel
like they can't compare to strong human
characters and never will but here oda
is definitely spending a significant
amount of focus and time on hyping them
up clearly the marines made these guys
to be at least warlord level to replace
the old warlord system and yes warlord
level doesn't mean much because it
varies a lot depending on the warlord
but you get what i mean mihawk still
better be able to wreck them all the
same that's all i'm saying then finally
we find out that blackbeard didn't
actually leave empty-handed captain kobe
the hero of the rocky port incident has
been abducted by one of the four
emperors blackbeard his current status
is unknown we're told word spreads
across the world and you know the straw
hats will find out about this soon as
well this is what makes blackbeard such
an interesting villain even when he
loses he wins it looked like he had to
walk away empty-handed but he turned it
around and got another huge bargaining
chip to work with and all i'm thinking
is wow blackbeard is doing a great job
of making luffy hate him obviously he's
the blame for the ace stuff and there
was already a lot of reasons for luffy
to dislike him but blackbeard just keeps
giving him more reasons like just
imagine when luffy hears how he handled
boa and then how he kidnapped kobe this
rivalry is heating up big time right now
and i would be very surprised if
blackbeard doesn't play a bigger part in
this arc but channel the pirate king
within and smash that like button if you
enjoyed this video and want to keep the
reviews coming always be a smashing
powder king rather than passing orochi
and youtube will reward you by sending
fireworks from wano straight to your
screen give it a shot it actually works
i gotta say i love this chapter let me
know your thoughts on everything
including blackbeard's playing with kobe
his new bounty his new power and so on
i'm so excited and while you wait for
next chapter to drop feel free to check
out my huge and growing one-piece
playlist that includes all mythical zone
users all admirals a one hour video on
shanks and much more link to that is in
the description and on screen right now
and until next time see you space
cowboys